a draw there are some problems there
because what i have noticed about magnus
is that he has a very wide repertoire he
can choose which way he's going to serve
and he tends to be very effective at all
we're going to see an owens defense
yeah so that is very rare with black you
can tell rajabov doesn't
believe in his chances in an open game
in a sicilian in a kingsport opening he
as black now he's about to set up with
the hippopotamus defense wow this looks
great
yeah black he's just gonna camp out on
his first three rows
keeping all the pieces on the board as
we predicted no
opening theory here a draw is the same
as a loss for rajabov so
it's all out for the win this is an
opening i employ a lot in blitz or
bullet chess
online because there's no clear plan for
the opponent and that's why we see
magnus already thinking
it's only move five he does castle the
white king
rajabov bringing his knight to the
center now there's no direct
confrontation no
white will control the first four ranks
black will hide out on his first
three ranks black slightly cramped but
super flexible i have to say
i've we've seen many grand masters try
this particular opening
with the black pieces and i have to say
the track record
in this event is actually quite poor
white tends to get an
overwhelm